I just want to show you something
this is the psychological power of the
device
what if I was sitting here talking to
you holding my phone
it's not buzzing it's not beeping no
one's calling me I'm just holding it
do you feel like you are the most
important thing to me right now
no you don't that's the association
so when we show up for a meeting
or we sit down for dinner with our
families and we put the phone on the
table
it sends a psychological message to
everyone sitting there that you are not
the most important thing to me right now
and putting the phone upside down is not
more polite
put into the airplane mode to take away
the Temptation that something's coming
in
and put it in a bag or on a shelf out of
sight
and this is how we should be interacting
with people giving them our full
attention
because
the idea is not that we hear the words
they say but that they feel heard
and this is one of the tricks
if you wake up in the morning and you
check your phone before you say good
morning to the person sitting next to
you you probably have a problem
if you have to take your phone from room
to room no matter where you go you
probably have a problem
and just like any recreational drug
the more you practice leaving it away
for example if you go out for dinner you
don't need four telephones leave one at
home leave one in the car you have one
with your spouse it's fine
if you have a client meeting leave it in
the car leave it in the bag never take
it out and it becomes easier and easier
and you find it easier not to be sucked
in by the by the the fear mongering as
well so like any addiction it just takes
a little work